[Music]
and I be humbled me spit out I'll be
humble Bahama oh em Bo I'm sorry
[ __ ] be humble in be humbleness
submitted by Bible and will go fast
that's exactly what it is something I
thought it attacked us hell is that I
don't know maybe it's not familiar it's
the mouse you have no childhood
it's called from americantale Fido with
a red solid Bible all with the red
clothes in the [ __ ] blue beret right
yeah a little mouse I emigrated to
America yeah and then there he was at
Universal Studios and yet homeys right
yes I remember because my cousin's
awesome yeah I think so a mother
rejected her son's perfect attendance
award at school arguing that other
children shouldn't be shamed for getting
sick that's [ __ ] so fatty that's so
petty dude you can't get perfect
attendance if you get sick yeah because
it's not perfect anymore oh you're not
attendings I thought it because it's
excuse him a doctor's note yeah I think
I got a perfect attendance award mystic
oh I never got actually I don't think I
ever done a perfect attendance ward I'm
sorry I should apologize for that I'm
lying
so this mom she refused the perfect
attendance award to her kids so the kid
was ready to get it and the mom
cock-blocked it yep pretty much
[ __ ] messed up so this mother her name
is Rachel she's 40 from the UK so she
cares more about other kids than her own
certified [ __ ] certified certified
[ __ ] like I Angus prime state USDA
biggest toy so this is Rachel Matt she's
looks nice so Rachel she had three kids
the oldest one is an 11 year old and he
has he has like a long-term illness
that's where he cares about me hunt all
right he has yeah she cares about strong
mom she cares about him the leaf the
second one maybe in the baby she loves a
lot
what finish your thought
so she posted this and this one on
Facebook she writes a lot oh no I said
you enjoy nothing better to do I was
kidding I'm gonna finish my realize a
bigger hater Rimmer I'm a comedian I
just make jokes
I'm not be free so she's saying that
there are four reasons as to why her son
will not be accepting though and they
call it 100% attendance award you would
hurt a bunch choice it doesn't seem like
it seems like it's her - so she's saying
the first reason is a failed reward
luck that you know that there's um that
he's been lucky that he hasn't gotten
sick or that he doesn't have a chronic
illness like his older brother for him
to still be able to attend school number
one number two a 100% attendance Awards
can't demonize the weakest so people
that do get sick or they do have chronic
illness so they you know they're being
kind of singled out by not getting this
award they're been getting sick
throughout the year so ago so that she's
also saying like can you imagine a
workplace that at the end of the week
they marked down all the people that
hadn't been sick and then they get
rewarded you're putting in that way they
do or is saying like we're all the
departments with the least number of
people off were rewarded in front of
everyone else
they do okay so she's saying that next
one is uh he had no control over his
100% attendance she was like anyone
should be getting the reward should be
me because I'm the one taking him to
school kind of thing he could be
ditching though yeah you can have 100%
control over his it my pair saw me walk
out to go to school all the time but I
walk my ass all the way to the mall what
you're talking about
yeah what you think he doesn't and her
fourth point is that they will be taking
the their kid out of school the last
five days
of the term and it's because that in
that family they value school and work
but they also know the importance of
making memories with the family so
they're going to be taking a trip to
Italy and she explains how the older son
won't be going and all that stuff but
those are her four points well obviously
she's too smart for this [ __ ] school
system that's why no I think cuz she
does her son I think she just feels like
damn this sucks like imagine if my son
you know how did my friend feel if he
doesn't have control over his illness
yeah well she's lucky because her family
is intelligent because I went through
elementary thinking that the you know
the perfect attendance was a lottery
thing so I lottery
yeah so during the the assembly right at
the end of the year like I'm just there
like oh you didn't sit for literally in
your perfect attendance [ __ ]
certificate this year please let them
forget or would you please none of our
guests that I [ __ ] miss a day you
know it was it could you don't know what
attendance man or perfect I didn't know
what that is I just thought a man like
perfect you know why I don't give two
shits about this because the kids have
got the perfect attendance award nobody
give a [ __ ] about an award I did as a
little kid Rogers in elementary school
and I'm not a loser but in elementary
school like I like the I like getting
rewarded [ __ ] you everyone likes it and
rewarding I'm not the perfect attendance
award only give a [ __ ] about that I
didn't even know what that was David I
just wanted to be on there with a
[ __ ] certificate in a gold yeah risen
that [ __ ] hangs down and your dare
with the principal asked a picture but
you didn't know the difference between
attendance and there's like all these
other awards that you can get yeah uh
well I sucked at the student I just
wanted one sucker that perfect or tennis
board was like was like pity award
though now what's something that nobody
cared about that wasn't my point my
point was because he said nobody give a
[ __ ] about that no I did
I can't you're [ __ ] weird look I
didn't even know you
bet you wanted some shiny [ __ ] you
[ __ ] the edge of the hall you know
what there was a class of wards right
I always got like the funniest or
whatever but that [ __ ] is like
construction paper [ __ ] printout it
doesn't have the gold school you're all
mine is not a certificate with the
[ __ ] ribbon dude my god I got most
improved I think I'm most improved or I
got most humorous horrible class one I'm
talking about the whole elementary
school up like assembly one yeah
when everyone's lined up outside yeah
well we got those far assembly what I
remember just getting them for that -
yeah it's like all the all the fourth
graders all the fifth graders all the
sixth graders like all there that's a
big-ass [ __ ] I got and I got it and then
I have a gold seal thing at the bottom
for our student of the month and yeah
the perfect attendance perfect
attendance student of the month you know
but those like most improve funniest and
claps all those that's inside the club
because it too many students that school
or [ __ ] never affected me because I mean
is because when I was a kid I welcome to
condo and I just wanted to Goldman Oh
also you're [ __ ] a family ear from a
family of oh sorry
you're family of two and you're the
oldest no manners
oh yeah I think uh kid are your plug now
on I'm in this particular school what
they do for all the kids I got perfect
attendance they'll take them to like a
place where they can like a field trip
and they get to have fun oh yeah danger
zone will not be attending that but
instead will be going to Italy with the
family you know what because I I know
how he feels I got pneumonia one time in
the fourth grade
and I came back and some of the kids
that didn't like me call me pneumonia
[ __ ] okay ammonia [ __ ] your teacher I
don't know I'm going to be close maybe
she was explaining to the students like
you know why the loudest
[ __ ] isn't in the class anymore and
she was like well yeah his [ __ ] this
[ __ ] got pneumonia so don't be like
him or you're going to get pneumonia or
whatever right and I was gone like I
couldn't breathe out
Hospital [ __ ] man water was all of them
alums and [ __ ]
and then I came back to school and then
this kid like he was playing and he's
like hey you know Mon your [ __ ] and I
was like [ __ ] you too
I was dying what's that mean do get
offended by everything like bartender
over here yeah so far tender no but yeah
I remember in my school though the
perfect attendance Awards they would
have like a pizza party with only the
kids I got professional tennis it'd be
like a sentence to want to get that
award at high school [ __ ] high school
I'm talking about elementary held high
done no I don't know where did you hear
high school yeah I think that's right
from my school high school because like
I remember that what we were learning
multiple cases and [ __ ] people who could
get up to the higher multiplication [ __ ]
you got a certain amount of topping for
ice cream fried eggs and [ __ ] and so if
you got the higher you went up on the
multiplication tables on a certain time
frame you got more toppings on your
[ __ ] banana sundae
just say all I had was the ice cream but
I could not do that [ __ ] my you know I
was it
I just didn't get it until my dad was
like this is how you do it
so I came back and I had a [ __ ]
cherry on top [ __ ] just one rose that's
obsessive talk all cuz that's the last
thing you put on the football and
explain that for you don't forget one
banana I had whipped cream
I had chopped the drizzle nut and a
[ __ ] cherry on top I was like suck my
dick [ __ ] I don't think I went to a
school where they separated better
students from the lesser students and
gave them rewards or something or maybe
I just don't remember but the cool thing
about that is though it teaches people
that you don't just get [ __ ] for just
trying I like that that's like though
even when you have to earn something
exactly that's like the whole [ __ ]
Manny Pacquiao fight where he [ __ ]
didn't get his belt
you know what about what about if you're
[ __ ] stupid like me
and you think all these things there's I
don't make I didn't make a connection
about my work and my effort equals this
gold star on the wall with my name on it
I just saw my name with all these lines
and then
like everyone's names with gold stars
and I'm like [ __ ] man I'm like I want
one but I just come into class hoping
that I get another one but I don't I
don't think you thought it was i rolling
dice issue I just thought it was
favorites I was like oh it's [ __ ]
teacher like this [ __ ] that's why he
has five gold stars there's no baby got
the whole class major now yeah
dude everything with a lot o to me no
one explained to me or maybe they did
and I didn't know how to pay attention I
think that's at what happens here all
day yeah [ __ ] school up until sixth
grade I graduated without knowing the
connection between my efforts and my
[ __ ] work equals this gold star we
believe you yeah we do you you've
discovered that all the [ __ ] answers
to the test are going to be in the
politics is racing so we get it when I
made a discovery man I was like that's
how [ __ ] easy it was I thought was
just like some baby [ __ ] oversight yo
when I first had this pencil dawg
you know that patient up top doctor
before I didn't realize how stupid
school was because think about it right
this is this whole time I'm thinking all
right I got to read this book memorize
it and then come up with my own theories
and whatever questions they ask me I
have to come up with my own thoughts
that's what I thought
throughout my whole [ __ ] life in
elementary critical thinking I knew
you're you and the kid with a house car
that's why Oh like I'm not going to read
this book they're gonna make me to come
up with my own thoughts with whatever
information is on here and I'm gonna
have to ride it out I'm not ready for
that
how come your person help you out on
that because what did you stop for [ __ ]
cause look if you sue it that's what I
wanted never hit you because she's
frigid they were disciplining me that
way hope you guys enjoyed that video but
if you didn't guess what you can
directly contribute to the articles that
we discussed just cruise on over to the
description box below click on that link
to submit your article also for the next
video click rat up hey